voici navy north field
alors je vous dis tout de suite bonsoir
madame enfin messier parce que je sais
que je n'ai pas beaucoup quand on dit
bonsoir nom alors je vous le dis aussi
on doit pas dire bonsoir on dire bonsoir
madame
et puis bien sûr d'apprendre plein de
choses voilà fort madame ça le rend si
vous pouviez c'est d'éviter les ok
leccia tout ça parce que la baronne aime
pas trop quoi
mais ça va de soi quand on est bien
ainsi j'ai dit bien se tenir
ne vous inquiétez pas on va parler de
votre livre qui s'appelle l'amour est
une affaire de femmes chez robert
laffont
vous savez comment on fait un
c'est votre c'est votre septième livre
sauf que quant à psa et à la fois ça
sans briller plus ce monsieur n'à fille
en face de quelqu'un vous appelle
monsieur lavis en même temps c'est une
fois un flic qui m'a avant de passer
avec libre on va parler
[Applaudissements]
l'un parcours absolument incroyable et
nenad in l'hôpital y est rue agathe à
puteaux votre mère était ouvrière votre
père inconnu et votre beau père était
gardien de la paix vous viviez dans un
petit deux pièces obscures
l'eau est fallu aller chercher dans la
cour et votre chat l'évasion s'était la
lecture et vous aviez trouvé un livre
poussiéreux dans un placard au fond d'un
vieux placard
c'était le savoir vivre écrit par la
marquise louise d'alc et quand vous
lisiez ce livre vous aviez l'impression
de présider des dîners somptueux où des
hommes en habit s'incliner devant des
femmes 5e et jusqu'à terre vous imaginez
en lisant ce bouquin il vit entouré de
lys et de roses
et puis quand vous ouvrir les yeux vous
reveniez dans votre petit deux pièces de
puteaux et celle là c'est là qu'est né
vers toute cette ambition de s'en sortir
oui mais à vous entendre j'ai
l'impression que c'est les misérables
j'ai l'air de causette dans votre
impression non pas du tout écouter mais
dans le quartier tout le monde était
comme moi donc il y avait pas de raison
que je ne sois plus plus pauvres que les
autres crise que les autres on était
tous à la même enfant oui alors le
premier amour s'appelait georges truchot
oui c'est un fils de chiffonniers qu'il
allait vous cherchez des fleurs dans les
poubelles c'est très beau cette histoire
c'est vraiment une très belle histoire
et leur vous était pas terrible quand
vous étiez petit en cas de non mais les
taches de rousseur non non facile de
faire j'ai changé si vous les fait avant
lui ça serait bien mais vous saviez déjà
séduire très tôt vous avez compris oui
j'ai appris très vite très vite
c'est quoi votre secret je crois que
c'est la gaieté je vais vous dire il
n'ya pas un homme qui résiste à la gaîté
d'une femme à la gentillesse la gaieté
un peu de terreau version bien entendu
cette fois elle est comme vous ma femme
c'est vrai elle est réglée très enjoué
comme ça le matin en se réveillant qui
la perversion aussi
bien alors j'ai commencé à travailler à
l'âge de 14 ans chez nike bauer donc
c'est deus de voiture et vous dit dès
que j'ai eu le certif je suis parti de
chez moi donc pour travailler mais quand
vous a été nommé docteur honoris causa
de l'université de jérusalem
vous avez déclaré pas mal pour quelqu'un
qui n'a pas son certif
oui c'est vrai je ne les ai jamais eues
budget n'est jamais venu enfin il
fallait bien qu'un jour je dis que
lorsque je voulais travailler que je la
vois là mais très courageuse et un peu
pour arrondir vos fins de mois vous
nettoyez les escaliers d'immeubles où
vous habitiez non mais là c'est était
très jeune pour arrondir ses fins de
mois
c'est dans la bio ensuite vous travaillé
dans une fabrique de laine vous mettez
des pelote dans des sacs
vous avez quand même une première vie
qui était pas drôle du tout non sans
faire les misérables
il ya des tas de femmes qui sont comme
moi aujourd'hui et elles vont pas nous
mais c'était absolument patrie je vous
assure pas du tout alors beaucoup
d'ambitions un très jeune vous dites je
préférais rester chez moi que sortie mal
accompagné oui et c'est normal je vais
vous dire quand vous voulez réussir dans
la vie il ya des tas d'hommes autour de
vous les tas de gens qui vous sollicite
pour pour être avec vous parce que vous
êtes mignonne vous avez 16 ans bon moi
je préférais rester chez moi que d'être
mal accompagné mais la compagnie veut
dire par un homme qui pouvait rien vous
apporter enfin exactement vidéo dj
deviner là j'arrive à la fiche numéro 69
vous connaissez le principe
c'est vous qui me posais une question
m'amène aaron les rôles sont inversés
évidemment pour une fois c'est bien en
tant que femme de banquier je voudrais
savoir si vous avez un compte non
déclaré dans une banque étrangère
alors voilà la question c'est bien ça me
permet de le dire et alors que du 18 et
non on avait eu sa fille avait bien
proposé
non je sais pas faire ça je paye mes
impôts et tout mais je ne suis pas fort
la demande alors beaucoup d'ambition et
on peut dire pas une grosse vertus non
plus n'ont écouté tout dépend ce que
c'est que ce qu'est ce que vous appelez
que la vertu est ce que c'est un homme
deux hommes trois hommes qu'est ce que
c'est oui il ya des limites quelque part
bon je vais pas vous dire exactement si
j'étais vertueuse ou pas j'étais une
jeune fille de mon temps je crois
qu'aujourd'hui elles se valent un jour
vous tombez sur le peintre jean gabriel
domergue
vous avez rendez vous avec une amie qui
voulait poser pour lui et en fait l'idée
qui vous voit il vous dit vous commencer
demain matin absolument et je vais vous
dire c'était la soeur d'elisabeth
tessier c'est travailler avec moi et qui
mettait les pelotes de laine dans les
sacs
c'est parce qu'elle est devenue
d'ailleurs et voilà et donc à 16 ans
finalement vous commencé à poser pour
jean gabriel domergue devient long cou
comme ça un petit nez en trompette très
parisienne comme les parisiennes de
kiraz 1 et à leur première séance de
poses humiliation aux évier oublié de
vous laver les cheveux comment une fille
comme vous en la couille ça c était ça
peut arriver nul n'est parfait
elle nous a renvoyés chez vous il vous a
dit il ya toujours du savant dans une
maison exactement à envoyer chez vous
vous installez vous l'avez les je vous
ai une très bonne leçon je n'ai jamais
faillir là ce soir c'est bien alors
domergue est devenu votre pygmalion et
alors là vous avez connu un peu le tout
paris puisque anna de noailles par
exemple donné aux séances de pose et
rentrer dans le milieu parisien grâce à
ça non oui enfin rentrer dans le milieu
parisien je voulais entrer dans le
milieu du théâtre parisien alors de
modèles et de meneuse de revue
comédienne lisons d'une certaine façon
même si vous êtes très humble par
rapport à vos talents de comédienne
vous avez fait beaucoup de films
beaucoup de pièces mûri j'ai beaucoup
travaillé en angleterre j'ai tout fait
surtout beaucoup de comédies musicales
et puis j'ai fait l'olympia j'ai fait la
bcge effet les capucines
ouais et voilà bon géré et comment il
fait vous avez commencé sur les planches
à 17 ans avec francis lopez et après
vous allez acheter c'est vous qui
doublent et martine carol dans caroline
chérie et oui c'était devenu le pied de
grue en u oui elle voulait pas un
centime car on veut bien mais si on peut
et qui vous double maintenant pour
l'essentiel vous avez présenté les
premiers bikini en tournée mondiale où
j'étais speakerine à l'olympia oui et à
cette époque que vous rencontrez
brassens et alors il était fou d'amour
de vous et vous vous intéressez pas du
tout faut pas exagérer fou d'amour nous
sommes enfin il était charmant mais
comme je voulais dit tout à l'heure il
faut savoir dire non quelques fois oui
alors il a écrit ça pour vous brassens
jolies fleurs savais pas qu'il
s'agissait de jouer en entendant cette
chanson parce que je crois que vous
inviter à dîner vous lui disiez non
demain quoi c'était la tactique pour le
faire fait revenir bien sûr qu'il ait
passé d'argent c'est pas qu'il avait pas
assez d'argent c'est que c'était pas mon
genre donne d'une part et puis et puis
j'avais d'autres ambitions pourquoi ça
c'était pas brassens est alors au cinéma
vous faites des rôles secondaires dans
des séries b vous étiez un peu numéro
deux derrière bardot à l'époque non oui
j'ai travaillé avec bar de huy et les
critiques disait que vous aviez des gens
de spirituel et vous étiez une ingénue
permet ainsi reste en termes plus
tellement un génie pervers s'est
terminée aujourd'hui d'abord je suis
passé je ne sais même pas s'il y en a
encore
vous avez hollywood et vous refusez
hollywood vous refuser un contrat de
sept ans hollywood pourquoi parce que
d'abord je veux dire je ne suis pas
quelqu'un que l'on peut mettre dans une
cage
donc là c'était vraiment une très belle
cage dorée mais qui ne me convenait pas
et puis resté sept ans dans un endroit
où vraiment je n'avais aucun contrôle
non je préférais revenus
il fallait vous faire peroxydée les
cheveux avoir un fiancé officiel à effet
blonde comme marilyn monroe c'était pas
mon style et tout le monde devait être
comme elle et voilà on vous dit j'ai
compris que je ne serai jamais une
grande star j'avais pas le physique et
si je voulais franchir une nouvelle
étape
ça ne pouvait être que par le mariage
c'était le but si vous voulez que je
m'était imposé c'est de trouver un mari
ouais pas forcément puissant pas
forcément riches y pouvait être
immensément riche et elle
permettez des limites toujours non
j'aurais pu épouser un je peux pas vous
dire - prix nobel
quelqu'un qui avait vraiment le pouvoir
j'aime le pouvoir alors la richesse et
la puissance effectivement vous fasciner
et vous dites avec pas mal d'humour
derby il ya toujours des femmes qui
tombe toujours sur le plombier moi
chaque fois que j'ai vérifié le vers moi
c'est la vérité mais je vous dis on ne
sait pas pourquoi les hommes riches
attire certaines femmes pourquoi est ce
que les hommes sont attirés par des
femmes comme moi j'ai bon aujourd'hui
c'est vrai que si on fait la course et
rockefeller où elle a pas d'autre
d'abord parce qu'on a la même ville même
way of life on connaît les mêmes gens
c'est plus facile votre surnom c'était
quand même la ruée vers l'or non je
dirais plutôt que c'était la ruée vers
le diamant vous fait un petit rendre et
là vous tombez sur un et demande
rothschild donc dans un dîner en 1960
vous dites la beauté d'un homme ça m'a
jamais vraiment compté pour moi
non non et je trouve que ça n'a aucune
importance à guingamp ce jour peut-être
ouais ouais avant de passer à table soit
vous rencontrez dandiner il vous dit
vous portez un beau diamant dommage
qu'ils soient faux et c'était vrai que
c'est vrai et c'était vrai après vous
retrouvée assise à côté de lui il avait
une boîte une boîte à pilules où il y
avait une alliance cacher et voulu vivre
votre alliance est sûrement vrai mais
c'est pas sûr qu'elle soit sa place
c'est normal quand on l'a marié je sais
pas où est la vôtre si l'électeur doit
pardon en principe c'est là où elle doit
être
vous voulez droit est revenu enchanté
gens mais attendez ça veut dire qu'il
enlevait son alliance pour aller sans sa
femme dans les dîners exactement vous
avez tout compris et surtout jamais ça
vous ne seriez jamais seul non alors il
ya un problème c'est qu'elles
demanderont s'il venait de se marier
alors c'est difficile de faire divorcer
un homme un homme marié depuis trois ans
n'ont écouté c'est pas moi qui lui ai
demandé le divorce je pense que le
couple ne devait pas très bien marché et
puis et puis voilà c'est ce qu'on
appelle le coup de foudre nous le
premier soir le premier soir quand vous
êtes vu çà a été lauréate versailles je
peux dire que j'ai été très séduit tweet
le coup de foudre non non simplement
c'est pour les emails qui m'ont bien
est-ce que vous avez coucher le premier
soir c'est vrai c'est une question qu'on
va avoir beaucoup sur mon nom mais je
sais que je vous réponds oui tout de
suite non mais je sais que c'est
important je crois qu'il faut faire
l'inversé voyez-vous monsieur bachy il
faut toujours faire atteindre un homme
quand même temps vous l'avez fait
attendre alors et man non non non non
non non non non non je crois qu'il a dû
attendre au moins deux mois oui deux
mois je partais aussi en tournée alors
c'est pour ça et vous vous êtes resté
pendant trois ans dans l'ombre d'une
certaine façon vous l'avez laissé marier
avec cette femme
et vous vous attendiez vous étiez pas
mal et vous avez acheté un appartement
la muette quand même ce qu'elle veut
dire qu'enfin qu'à leur rapport à 4
pièces et la bulle est sympa oui mais en
fait j'avais autre chose avant faut pas
exagérer toujours les rues thématique
jours alors il finit par divorcer
vous êtes bien pris là et alors problème
c'est qu'il dit je peux pas je peux pas
t'épouser parce que tu n'es pas juive
oui mais vous qu'à cela ne tienne
miracle vous êtes enceinte
oui j'attends mon fils oui c'est le flux
de nom mais ça tombait bien disons
vraiment ça tombait bien non écoutez un
enfant ça ce programme cet homme n'avait
pas d'enfant il voulait un enfant nous
avons fait un enfant vous avez un peu de
temps que j'ai accompli non non pas du
tout là haut la ola pas du tout cher
monsieur alors ça vous vous trompez
qu'on peut me dire moi je vous pose non
mais vous me posez la question je vous
réponds non
cet homme voulait est un enfant il s'est
dit voilà une ficelle je vais faire un
enfant
ah bon donc il était alité au courant ah
oui vaut mieux marié en catastrophe en
robe de chambre à l'hôpital parce que
mariée chez moi pas l'hôpital attention
si marié chez moi en robe de chambre
c'est vrai puisque j'étais couché
j'attendais mon fils et là vous vous
convertissez au judaïsme et vous êtes
accepté par la famille
ça a été difficile pour vous de
d'apprendre le talmud et tout ça pas du
tout absolument pas à partir du moment
où vous êtes vous êtes capable de tout
enregistrer et d'être une bonne élèves
je les écoute j'ai été convertie par le
grand rabbin kaplan kaplan qui était un
homme est absolument extraordinaire et
j'ai passé je dois dire 2 à me convertir
et maintenant donc vous êtes de religion
juive
seulement moi j'ai un canapé convertible
à l'islam et alors vous dit en parlant
de ça d'ailleurs en parlant du fait que
les rothschild a accepté une fille qui
venait quand même d'un milieu très
modeste vous dites je me demande si les
marchés les époux marché aurait voulu
d'un rothschild comme gendre je ne le
crois pas c'est ce réveil pour ceux qui
l'auraient sûrement pas ouais bien que
bien que je vais vous dire qu'entre
schild a paraît il ya plus de ja premier
géant il ya plus de frontières je pense
que oui son nom magique que si monsieur
marché avait il avait eu une fille jeu
en définitive je crois qu'il devrait
accepter alors il avait pas mon
caractère à monsieur barre encore un
édito la soupe au lait c'est vrai vous
disent ils en auraient fait fuir plus
d'une wii et et macho le baron et j'aime
les hommes machos flannum comme les
hommes doivent l'être
on essaie de terminer ce que la liste
est pas terminée maintenant des matches
à ces matches où tu es gaulliste et
aimer comme tous les hommes armés
exigent oui les coureurs ça écoutez moi
je connais pas d'hommes qui ne soit pas
coureurs c'est vrai vous dites là la
fidélité masculine n'existe pas à mes
yeux ça n'existe pas mais il en faisait
cette phrase merveilleuse que je
voudrais que toutes les femmes de france
écoute aimer un homme c'est accepter de
le voir heureux avec une autre que vous
[Applaudissements]
et
ça me change de isabelle alonso c'est
sur la générosité c'est aimer
profondément quelqu'un beaucoup de
femmes vous disant j'adore mon mari
j'adore mon mari bon bah si tu n'aime
tellement laisse le vivre sa vie puis
vous vous aviez été sa maîtresse pendant
trois ans avant qu'ils vous épouser donc
malgré tout vous saviez qu'il avait des
maîtresses puisque les ou 40 de votre
côté vous pratiquez aussi le je n'ai
jamais lu de vous quelque part n'est
entendu non donc il faut avant tout être
discrète mais alors c'est vrai quand
quand vous parlez de vous vous comparez
souvent une geisha voire à une esclave
ou dit la femme est fait pour plaire et
écouter ça me paraît normal quand on
aimera entre de 2,2 du bureau qu'il a
envie de vous parler
la moindre des choses est de l'écouter
tout pour éviter de vivre ça c'est à
dire que vous n'êtes pas tout accepter
plutôt qu'un divorce
oui parce que vous dites il vaut mieux
être trompé que divorcé cette demande
moins de formalités exactement c'est
très cynique mais quand on voit les
désastres si vous voulez de ses enfants
d'occasions ouais moi ça me rend malade
tous ces jeunes qui se marient quatre
ans après divorce c'est pas les enfants
qui sont l'occasion les bourdons les
informations les enfants d'occasions
pour le prochain si vous prenez la dame
vous prenez les gosses avec bon et si
vous prenez les gosses avec c'est
vraiment on voulait on vous les
présentez vous êtes obligés d accepter
sont des enfants d'occasions je suis
désolé je prends peur mais non non moi
non plus je n'aime pas mais c'est la vie
qui est comme ça
bon et si les gens faisaient un tout
petit peu plus attention avant de se
marier il y aurait pas tous les drames
qu'il ya aujourd'hui et voilà donc au
bar dont les gens sont crus aux salles
c'est ça le fond du problème
donc pas divorcer et un grand conseil
aussi dans la grande série des grand
conseil de la baronne de rothschild
jamais avoué
c'est la principale des choses si vous
avez vous êtes vous êtes morts d'abord
il ne faut jamais demander à votre mari
est ce que tu m'as trompé oui parce que
bien entendu vous êtes c'est dramatique
d'entendre oui je vous dit il va
chercher un peu à se faire pardonner
comme auprès de sa mère mais en fait une
femme lui pardonnera jamais jamais façon
voix lasse jamais alors messieurs s'il
vous plaît ne vous ai jamais n'avoue
jamais guy mardel il a alors vous
vouliez créer un moment je pense que
c'est devenu de cette histoire une
assurance divorce
oui j'en ai parlé ce matin justement
avancer ça tient toujours pas ce que
c'est il ya longtemps de ça c'était
vraiment dans les années sur des bus de
70 des chrétiens sûr je vais quelque
chose j'ai mais vous savez alors quoi
combler l'absence d'assurance du bord
c'est à dire que je voudrais à partir du
moment où les hommes divorce et les
femmes divorce
ils doivent normalement payer une
pension alimentaire mois-ci l'homme et
de bonne foi il paiera si
malheureusement il ne l'est pas la femme
se retrouve sans rien s'il perd sa
situation même s'il veut payer alors je
crois qu'on pourrait créer si vous
voulez une assistance ou les assurances
se substituerait à l'état ou aux maris
voilà mais alors pourquoi vous avez
arrêté d'en parler pendant 30 ans parce
que ça a énervé demande non pas du tout
non c'est que chaque fois que j'ai
présenté le projet on a dit c'est pas
réalisable c'est un encouragement au
divorce puis quand on voit qu'il y en a
tellement je me dis j'aime bien
l'encourager du tout par exemple 7 pour
le salaire maternel
oui j'ai donc pensé que les femmes
devraient toucher un salaire pour
s'occuper des enfants ne rapporte pas
pour toutes les femmes pas pour toutes
les femmes faisait des femmes surtout
obligé de travailler qui gagne très peu
d'argent est alors à ce moment là je dis
pourquoi ne donne-t-on pas un salaire au
lieu de créer des crèches de construire
sans arrêt sans arrêt de nouveaux
établissements pour mettre des enfants
qui ont besoin de leur mère et des
femmes qui ne sont pas fait pour
travailler mais bon au moins qu'on leur
donne un salaire et tout le monde y
gagne en selle qui peuvent et qui ont
l'intelligence ou les études vous
houle envie surtout celles qui ont envie
pourquoi pas moi je fais absolument ravi
tout à fait pour vous pensez quoi des
chiennes de garde
écoutez moi j'admire beaucoup madame
alonso parce qu'elle est elle un
parcours fantastique
elle est une très grande chef
d'entreprise j'estime que cette femme a
beaucoup de mérite de défendre
pardon pensez quoi des chaînes de govou
qui avait monté les lévriers afghans de
garde
rappelons l'histoire non je crois qu'il
en faut
je serais incapable de faire le travail
qu'elle fait ça à la table bon j'ai agi
d'une autre façon mais je pense qu'elle
est très très très utile au contraire
ouais vous la soutenez je ne dis pas que
je la soutiens surtout les nations je la
soutiens aux je vais vous dire dans le
domaine de la génétique touche est bonne
la place attendue maintenant
vous étiez chez vous aussi s'il vous
plaît nadine de rothschild finalement
votre façon d'envisager la vie conjugale
ainsi vous ne nous le raconter est-ce
que c'est pas finalement de la
prostitution bourgeoise j'ai épousé un
homme riche c'est vrai
mon mari mon mari n'était pas l'aider
sûrement pas un homme fidèle et gelé
quand même gardé pendant 40 ans et je
voulais dit quand vous aimez quelqu'un
vous fait des sacrifices peu importe les
sacrifices vous avez affirmé je suis
contre le divorce et mon mari était un
homme extraordinaire j'étais sa femme et
je le suis un steak et voilà si c'était
à refaire je recommence tout de suite
l'amour est une affaire de femmes chez
robert laffont par aline de rothschild
donc bajoues demandé de recommencer
ronaldinho il faut apprendre il faut le
faire tant que les pieds tu es fort à
clément ténue l'asie à leurs ébats fils
montrez-lui 1-2-3 et intérêts alors donc
dans l'avant propos du livre vous
évoquez la disparition du baron d'une
façon assez tendre d'ailleurs
effectivement
et puis vous parler des femmes célèbres
que vous avez connu ou approché comme
actrice ou comme baronne de rothschild
alors on va essayer de les passer en
revue un petit peu vous dire quelles
sont leurs spécificités
la première catégorie c les
marathoniennes alors dans cette
catégorie il ya par exemple jackie
kennedy
camilla parker bowles qu'est-ce qu'ils
ont de particulier les marathoniennes ce
sont des femmes qui aiment le pouvoir ce
sont des femmes qui ont envie d'être
célèbre donc elles savent qu'elles ne
peuvent être célèbre qu'à travers un
homme donc elles choisissent
effectivement l'homme qui va les mettre
sur un piédestal et qui sera d'elle la
star ou considérée comme une
marathonienne vous je pense oui oui
alors appris l ai pas de chance aurait
évidemment il ya lister leurs il ya
marilyn monroe christina onassis romy
schneider
j'ai dis pas que c'est myriam alors je
suis pas que ce sens pas les pas de
chance je dis que ce sont des midinettes
qui veulent absolument que l'amour soit
au rendez vous bon l'amour peut l'être
cinq minutes mais pas toute une vie donc
c'est pour ça qu elisabeth a tellement
divorcer que remy malheureusement est
morte d'amour elle est morte d'amour
parce que c'est très charmant de dire il
faut qu'on aime quand même à tout prix
mais c'est pas tout la vis ne pensez
qu'à un moment mais c'est plus d'infos
continues et quand même non je crois que
la passion la passion ces cinq ans je
parle là patients physique
bon après vous faites un accord vous
fait vous avez une vie avec des enfants
vous avez une vie très remplie mais ça
n'est plus du tout la même chose vous
n'êtes plus la maîtresse vous êtes la
femme l'épousé la mère des enfants
l'accompagnent c'est différent ne pensez
pas qu'on puisse être à la fois la maman
et la [ __ ] vous a sûrement pas ouais
sûrement pas et heureusement d'ailleurs
alors après il ya les mama alors celles
qui font des bons petits plats pour
garder leur mari alors il ya sophia
loren et je savais pas maria callas
c'était comme ça dans la glace
oui c'était une femme oui comment je les
ai vus vivre avec
avec onassis et c'était vraiment la mama
ouais
les coéquipières là c'est simone
signoret que mon temps hillary clinton
avec bill clinton son légendaire pardon
et charges tony chard alors c'est quoi
ça c'est ce que normalement une femme
doit être un moment de sa vie
oui et ça me paraît tout à fait normal
moi j'étais une partenaire idéale avec
mon mari c'est à dire que ont travaillé
ensemble dans beaucoup de choses et
c'est pour ça que je dis même si nous
avions divorcé il m'aurait posé parce
qu'on était on était une espèce de 10
l'extraordinaire les indépendants coria
diana mouna ayoub c'est quoi les
caractéristiques et indépendante
ce sont des femmes qui veulent vivre
avec l'argent de leurs maris ce ouais
voilà
et ça c'est très difficile parce qu'une
fois que vous avez cette célébrité je
pense qu'il n'y a pas beaucoup d'hommes
qui s'intéressent à vous ah oui parce
que vous avez de l'argent c'est très
difficile pour une femme d'être riche
seul il faut toujours un homme derrière
une femme savait plus terminé baronne
avec les admirables mais quand l'abbé
gamme que plus personne ne connaît les
mesures sociales et de rêver pierre
labbé gun grace kelly
oui farah diba oui en quoi elles sont
admirables non elles ont elles ont tenu
leurs engagements ils ont signé un
contrat ils sont allés au bout de leurs
oeufs de ce qu'elle avait signé moi je
trouve ça normal et bien
alors vous comprendrez comment les
aimants anna lindh et rothschild qu'on
vous fasse une interview alerte aux
roses
on a vous juge pas pendant les ting
en approche marketing
le lieu idéal pour faire l'amour en on
va tous les lieux sont possibles d'abord
un peu d'imagination rôle c'est plutôt
oui plutôt que le métro connaît le mot
incroyable
jason a un beau chercher la sécurité ou
la performance la sécurité
est-ce que vous avez besoin de faire
l'amour pour aimer ou des mets pour
faire l'amour
j'ai besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
oui préfère un homme qui fait bien
l'amour mais qu'un fidèle ou un homme
qui fait mal l'amour mais que les
fidèles un homme qui fait bien l'amour
et qui est un fidèle
vous préféreriez qu'un homme vous quitte
pour une femme ou pour un homme
je pense que là je serais très surprise
effectivement si c'était pour un homme
mais pippa non ça vous gênerait plus que
ce soit pour ça mais je n'aime pas dans
le flou non mais si vous aviez un homme
qui vous trompe avec un homme
vous auriez autant de compréhension que
c'était une femme si je ne peut pas
diriger je laisse faire
ouais voilà vous préférez un homme qui
couche avec une autre en pensant à vous
un homme qui couche avec vous en pensant
une autre c'est ce qu'on appelle quand
même si vous voulez quand un homme vous
dis je ne vous ai jamais trompé ma femme
alors je dis moi je vois pas la
différence entre un monsieur qui va de
5h à 7h avec une dame et revient à la
maison avec un grand sourire de bonne
humeur cas monsieur qui le soir parce le
même temps avec sa femme et qui pense à
la voisine n'est pas différent oui alors
vous préférez finalement dû coucher avec
une autre en pensant à vous exactement
elles s'ouvraient que dans le couple
pose même pas la question dans le couple
il faut tous diront rien savoir vous
pensez qu'il faut rien savoir à neuf ou
rien savoir
est-ce que vous pensez que embrasser
s'est trompé non non on peut embrasser
une femme ou un homme sans tromper
est-ce que sucer c'est tromper je ne
vais pas vrai plus
manning est il bon soir tavin la ville
depuis la disparition du baron edmond
votre épouse vous avez beaucoup de temps
libre
et comme vous avez beaucoup d'argent bah
vous visiter les endroits en europe où
ont lieu les plus belles histoires
d'amour voilà un c'est pas compliqué et
vous en rapporter un livre qui s'appelle
sur les chemins de la moure et s'était
dit et chez robert laffont
[Musique]
voilà alors tout le monde y passe ainsi
si et françois joseph lola montès et
louis de bavière la païva george sand
alfred de musset bien entendu roméo
juliette zelda et scott fitzgerald
joséphine napoléon la du baril week end
difficile
donc on commence avec 6,6 donc elle
faisait chambre commune avec françois
josef et à l'époque c'était une
révolution ça absolument et après non
après non parce que après il s'est passé
tellement de choses où elle est devenue
complètement une femme mystérieuse une
femme anorexique car elle a eu de tels
drames dans sa vie qu' effectivement
elle n'était pas mais j'ai très bien
connu cette impératrice à cause de ma
belle mère qui habitait le château de
pau nier ce qui venait régulièrement au
chanteur ronnie donc elle était une
grande habituée je dormais dans la
chambre de 6,6 quand je me suis marié
met donc à l'époque faire chambre
commune c'était mal vu
je le suppose la fin j'étais pas là
cette époque ah bon et bien là aussi si
si c'est elle qui choisissait la
maîtresse de son mari et c'est super
sympa à écouter et vous prêt il salue
10e plus écouter les clubs de rencontre
qu'est ce que c'est c'est ça ben c'est
pas les femmes qui choisissent les
maîtresses et leurs bungalows
non mais en grande partie si les femmes
laisse faire aujourd'hui c'est ça le
drame c'est que malheureusement elle non
plus si vous voulez 7 cette légèreté
pour pouvoir dire cette femme est
charmant aujourd'hui on divorce on
balance et puis c'est terminé tu ferais
ça toi non mais on dit que les hommes
aux sons ou à mon mari
qu'est ce que vous êtes marie vous êtes
marie way s'est donc conclue donc donc
nous sommes venus à arriver ça de
choisir les maîtresses de votre mari
elle sait pas l'idée c'est dupont
vous avez posé une question une farce
2011 à 10 vous rentrez chez vous un soir
auriez dutronc au lit avec une fille et
vous m'avez répond je suis dit qu'est ce
que vous faites mais a répondu je me
joins à eux
oui je mets beaucoup choqué j'ai mis 6
mois mon mari d une chose je te dirai au
lit avec un monsieur je dirais que c'est
pas toi
ah là là c'est sale c'est à l'éducation
mais oui mais est-ce que l'on a envie de
savoir où on n'a pas envie de savoir est
ce qu'on a envie de garder on a envie de
voir la personne s'éloigner c'est ouais
moi je ferais la même chose je vous
verrai au lit avec votre femme giresse
et pas lui
dans ce bouquin il ya 6 6 à lola montès
la pompadour bavaroise donc été avec
loïc premier de bavière qui perdra sans
trop de mer alors vous dites qu'elle n'a
pas su tirer profit de ces rencontres
c'est pas comme vous attendez attendez
moi j'ai eu très peu de rencontres mais
elles ont été très productives si leur
superbe et les femmes se galvaude elles
ne savent pas choisir ce mois là je
donne tout de suite à tout le monde n'y
a pas beaucoup de recul non plus c'est
difficile leur reviennent toujours à
cette phrase découdre que vous avez
c'est très beau temps dans la rue les
gens disent combien doit il ya 40
millions d'hommes sur la place de paris
en france bon il n'y a pas non plus que
des gens qui peuvent pas faire votre
bonheur les hommes font votre bonheur
pour pas être rothschild pour sa part il
ya aussi la païva la païva c'est celle
pour qui en a construit cet hôtel
particulier en bane et des champs
elysées qui est devenu bien triste
d'ailleurs je suis allé
c'est devenu un peu un peu triste parce
que à l'époque de la païva vous dites
qu'il ya des baignoires à 3 robin et
parce que la païva prenait des bains de
lait des tilleuls et peut-être de
champagne extraordinaire mais n'a pu des
filles comme ça assise mais
malheureusement non les hommes les
femmes ne font plus fantasmer les hommes
il vous achète peut-être une n'est pas
une machine une machine
fut pas moins computer ou un truc comme
ça mais ça va là ça s'arrête là quoique
ça les occupe aller computer françois ça
fait deux ans qu'elle trouve son compte
twitter pour faire son livre je peux
vous dire qu'elle est on sait où aller
au moins vous parlez de george sand
aussi oui appuyé par donc et alors il
faut un ménage à trois je savais pas et
que les docteurs bague et lola baï
d'ingrid bergman aussi alang lieberman
c'est terrible ce qui lui est arrivé
parce que rossellini roberto rossini
devenu fou d'amour pour elle il l'a
épousée il lui a fait un enfant le
fameux robertino et il est divorcé
oui il l'a fait durant c'est quand elle
a eu sept enfants après il l'aimait plus
parce que c'était la maman et mais c'est
normal c'est logique les femmes
s'imagine toujours quelles vont-être des
maîtresses toute la vie c'est pas vrai
on est maîtresse tant qu'il y as
séduction tant qu'il y a fantasme
après lorsqu'il y a un enfant la femme
fait plus fantasmer donc science exacte
je suis enfant quand le gosse était dans
la pièce à côté vous pouvez pas faire
des galipettes c'est normal c'est vrai
c'est vrai bon ben cheyrou l'enfant à la
pièce est de mettre assez loin quand
même
mais je vous dis
le deuil à deux changements le métro en
personne dans la chambre puis laissant à
chaque les noms me suis dit c'est selon
mais c'est madhi nous exposant les noms
et c'est pour ça que j'ai tenu quarante
ans sinon j'arrête pas fait je n'avais
pas fait trois jeux ouais mais vous
savez que françoise hardy et jacques
dutronc ils font vous fait toujours un
appartement à part c'est bien moi je
fais ça aussi ça c'est encore mieux
et alors nadine vous arriver finalement
au taj mahal et là vous achetez le kama
sutra lors s'agit comme je savais que
vous alliez m'en parler mais j'y crois
pas je n'avais pas à me dire que vous
avez attendu tout ce temps pour acheter
le kama sutra made in je vous donne ma
parole
et là j'ai réalisé que j'avais tout faux
ah bon mais tout faux en fait avec
et qu'est ce que ça aurait été si vous
l'avez du 40 ans en kama sutra y imagine
r j'avais toute la famille
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi je trouve idiot de toute l'histoire
non quand on connaît la vôtre c'est cent
fois mieux votre histoire ou non c'est
vrai que je suis une des rares femmes
d'abord je devrais être dans dans le
livre des records et s'est marié 40 ans
avec un homme comme était mon mari
c'était pas du site est pas facile tous
les jours vous savez ma dixième la plage
s'il vous plaît bien des photos
d'animaux sauna mais ce qui prouve
qu'ils prouvent leur ans et que j'ai
fait le tour du monde pour écrire ses
livres bien sûr oui les photos soir ça
c'est sûr et certain
je me suis donné beaucoup de mal pour
arriver à pondre un livre qui va faire
rêver mes lectrices parce que qu'est ce
qu'elles ont envie d'entendre c'est
parler d'amour
oui votre époux et déjà les biens
détenus mais oui oui oui je pense pas
qu'elles veulent acheter tout de suite
mais pourquoi mais vous allez lui
acheter non je ne pense pas moi ci se
tient si tu devrais je vais plutôt me
donner ce qu'ils me année là n'est même
pas question non mais c'est vrai cette
crise et comment saison ils ont fait
partie de la routine
quand j'étais petit on me disait que les
retire il ramasse et une aiguille par
terre mon père et ma mère il me faisait
croire quand 10 1 milliards d'eur en
ramassant des aiguilles par terre j'ai
essayé ça n'a pas marché
je connais des histoires de nadine non
oui vous étiez jeune comédienne vous
avez rencontré non mais ça commence
avant cela dit nenê en banlieue 1
donc c'est bien avant des jets
comédienne l'ouvrière dans un deux
pièces à aller chercher l'eau dans la
cour tu es donc c'était quand même assez
c'était quand même senti lui le premier
amour de nadine était chiffonniers oui
il allait vous cherchez des fleurs dans
les poubelles et vous les avez c'est une
très belle histoire un 14 ans vous vous
retrouvez en train de travailler dans
une usine de housses de voitures chennai
bowyer et mêmes pour faire un peu
d'argent de poche le soir quand vous
rentrez vous l'avez le marbre de
l'escalier de l'immeuble c'est un départ
oui voilà non mais attends c'est ça
c'est sûr j'ai envie de monter de
causette cet hymne s'est pas amusé mais
qu'en même temps il ya un côté cocasse
est très bien sorti et alors donc vous
commencé par rencontrer le peintre jean
gabriel domergue qui vous pour qu'ils
vous devenez modèle
ensuite vous êtes effectivement danseuse
meneuse de revue comédienne à l'âge de
17 ans il l'a hélas à partir de là le
jeu est là et la nadine se dit j'ai j'ai
pas le physique de la star quoi je vois
là quoi je vais pas y arriver comme ça
et elle se dit me reste une solution
c'est vrai elle se dit il reste le
mariage sauf que le mariage se sera
retirée quoi c'est sa maison de traque
non non pas de trac mon dieu j'étais
charmante j'étais tout à fait tout à
fait agréable pour un homme pourquoi
est-ce que hier soir était la traque de
mon côté pas du tout parce que c'était
un animal rare dont vous fait il faut
bien vous dire quand vous rencontrez une
femme c'est pas elle qui vient vous
chercher
c'est vous qui la découvrit ouais non
mais d'ailleurs la première fois les 10
h
moi je
la première fois qui vous a vu demande
rothschild il vous a dit vous êtes la
femme de ma vie c'est du vent voilà
seulement je n'ai pas cru d'ailleurs et
cela était vrai puisque ça a duré
quarante ans il vient de se marier en
plus et non mérite à pompe et nadine
ardente a trompé c'était dans des livres
mes enfants mes enfants jeunes d'imagés
toujours vous savez connaissez les trois
petits singes
ouais c'est vrai quand vous appelez à la
ruée vers l'or quand même à l'époque oui
on m'a toujours dit on m'a toujours dit
que j'étais fait pour avoir beaucoup
d'argent et vous auriez dû le voir
effectivement dans vos et la journée
vous voir vous allez me dire si mon
passé vous prédire le passé c'est bien
je crois que vous avez tessier fera
mieux enfin le fait bien ces frappes ont
raté une grande douche donc je continue
la légende de nadine de rothschild donc
effectivement vous rencontrez demande
rothschild mais évidemment rien un
handicap il vient de se marier avec une
fille sublime d'ailleurs il est
l'héritier d'une prestigieuse dynastie
financière il est juif pas vous ce qui
ne simplifie pas du tout les choses
après vous êtes converti mais mais ça je
n'ai pas trouvé qu'il y avait des
problèmes non jésus était juif marc joly
est absolument joseph aussi alors je
vois pas où elle prétend pas s'arranger
à l'amiable
et alors là pendant trois ans vous êtes
la femme de l'ombre
vous êtes dans un appartement à la
muette quoi la muette d'où le nom vous
savez aujourd'hui toutes les femmes sont
plus ou moins plus ou moins comment on
appelle commanditant je ne sais pas mais
je savais pas où vous voulez en venir
nous présenter jamais été maîtresse au
revoir
du conteur goulard dans une autre vie
romane de tête
donc voilà un jour vous êtes enceinte et
le baron vous épouser voilà non il ne
m'a pas non attention ça mais c'est pas
du tout ça c'est pas comme ça il a
décidé qu'un jour nous allions faire un
enfant
d'accord j'ai pris la décision en son
enceinte mais comment lui pouvait faire
un enfant dans la clandestinité
je vous savez écouter aujourd'hui le 5 à
7 qu'est ce que vous faites l'après midi
entre 5 et 16 mai et la voilà donc
finalement vous rentrez dans la famille
rothschild vous vous convertissez tout
va bien vous devenez la baronne de
rothschild et voilà et alors vous mettez
au point mort fameuse théorie à ce
moment là tient l'homme roi 1 l'homme
quand même roy l'homme est naturellement
un fidèle
c'est oui le mot farid et âme au féminin
ou masculin pour dire ma femme en
regardant la caméra je vais lui dire en
sortant d'accord la grande théorie
nadine c'est que le vrai féminisme c'est
de mener les hommes par le bout du nez
en fait c'est ça le vrai bien entendu on
a tous les pouvoirs et c'est un
euphémisme c'est pas honnête tu penses
il change pas après les excuses et le
laisser l'histoire elle tirait le diable
par la queue
pourquoi la queue
voilà
ça recoupe des emails la dignité sur un
carré sans cesse pourquoi là que la
bonne cuisine mais voilà que c'est moi
et je me demande tous la même chose et à
nadine pas renié à bruno maintenant ça
m'est adressée personnellement je sens
maintenant répond staline mais sans
aucun doute mais j'ai dû la trouvait
d'ailleurs voilà donc vous devenez une
grande spécialiste de la stratégie
amoureuse à ce moment-là nadine de
rothschild les règles de savoir vivre
les bonnes manières en facteur la table
le plan de table
exactement étiquette absolument et on va
faire une interview dîner chez les
rothschild
nadine est ce que le retard est
tolérable
je pars du principe que les gens qui
arrivent à l'heure ne doivent pas
attendre celui qui n'est pas à leur faim
alors je me mets à table avec mes
invités et les gens arrivent après et
croyez moi ils n'arrivent pas deux fois
en retard et vous fermait pas la porte
quand même voulu laisser arriver je
laisse arrivé il ya toujours la
vaisselle d'accord alors on doit
apporter quoi quand on va dîner chez les
gens en général on aurait des fleurs
recherche des décédés mais sinon retour
bienvenu
mais quand on a mangé chez moi ça rit
souvent jeunesse l arrogance et des amis
quand c'est des années quand c'est des
amis on apporte quoi nadine si j'invite
monsieur a dit nettement la faille il
m'envoie des fleurs à la main
c'était le lendemain ils sont déjà
partis moi chez les as peur mais vous
avez aussi le lendemain effectivement le
droit d'envoyer des fleurs alors faut-il
manger de tout ça on est obligées le
diabétique bravo non si vous avez un ami
diabétiques la maîtresse de maison sa
forme avant pour on sait que nos belles
montagnes appelé le monde à l'antenne y
avait forcément
alors question très importante
est ce que la télé peut rester invaincu
continue c'est une émission comme tout
le monde en parle gardez une spéciale
qui veut gagner des millions
question pour un champion je dînais avec
vous peut-être oui ah oui oui on est
happé en tout autre ton produit c'est la
télé non parce que je m'ennuierais
peut-être et cousins
xxl bien est ce qu'on peut faire du pied
sous la table d'une mais comment ces
mêmes recommandent aux femmes âge aussi
pour cent des pièces
est-ce que la main baladeuse est
autorisée ouais ça n'est pas ça n'est
pas comment dirais je sais pas tout ce
qui est un peu hypocrite sous la table
ce sont paul faire c'est un homme c'est
un homme était déjà arrivé de faire du
plat une femme en lui passant la main
comme ce coup là bas lui mais pas chez
moi raconte pas quoi dans la banque
rothschild en compte mais oui mais oui
oui oui c'est pas idiot on a découvert
autorisé la di grassi vous payer en
nature peut-être mais j'ai claqué
d'autres
pourtant c'est bien c'est jaime mayor
vraiment ménagé ce 40e fait pas mal
c'est pas tombées dans l'oreille de
faire ça non je cherche mon sens pleure
mais je le trouve pas bon il oubliée
chez toi n'en suis dit non mais je me
mets pas non c'est un peu too much pas
d'être québécois bien non nadine s'était
passé était passé devant tout le monde
d'accord en chine cochons d'inde au
milieu
thibault
début des cours non bien alors made in
est ce qu'on peut se soucier que sont
pas faussés s'est trompé
oui bien parce qu'on peut dire tout le
temps a dit par exemple en société mais
je suis surprise aujourd'hui par la
génération des femmes qui vous disent
ouais ouais tu dire oui bon quand vous
dites à un homme qui se disait est ce
que tu même si on vous demandait ce que
tu m'aimes elle répondait je t'aime
au lieu de dire oui je t'aime bien sûr
toute la différence a frustré quelle est
la pluie se tenir c'est le bordel c'est
pour ça qu'il ya la guerre ait pas là
mais priez madame plus sérieusement la
donne écoute moi qu'elle nous la bvk
nasa va partir mais coûte la plus grosse
gaffe qu'on puisse faire un dîner chez
toi de ne pas venir
ça c'est une belle rade petit julien
réponse est il un giron demain les
fleurs sont partis alors j'ai commandé
une couronne
m
les chemins
laurent a
je sais ce que tu fais quand tu ne quand
tu ne fais pas des missions en fait tu
es avec nadine en échange de quoi je
m'occupe d'elle je la sors je la fais
danser et j'avais fait pisser des chiens
et chats les tournées de linge à faire
donc je vais partir nadine tu rentres
pas trop tard d'accord le podium qui
cherche l'amour
m
bref l'europe serait génial c'est qu'il
est la même quand il n'est pas là quoi
un nom ce qui vous a pas dit si pour
n'était financé non mais sérieux
l'histoire c'est dimanche finance sa
pièce et on est fiancé mais celle
échange c'est normal c'est à dire nous
étions c'est jusqu'à quel point la fin
de la pièce est tout ouïe savoir moi je
vais préparer un truc vachement bien
genre à meyrin nadine de rothschild est
la veuve du baron edmond de rothschild
président de nombreux organismes hauteur
de vie joue à succès j'avais fait un
panégyrique absolument vous passez
beaucoup de temps dans le développement
et la promotion de vos propriétés
familiales marché non non c'est il vous
occuper de la promotion de votre vin
château claque dans le monde entier
vous avez des vignobles ou en afrique du
sud ou en argentine et en afrique du sud
en argentine au chili à bordeaux et puis
nous venons de racheter 90 hectares une
propriété qui s'appelle et l'aurait
quittée vers saint-émilion voilà
pourquoi s'emmerder
bah ouais bah ouais joue pour le bonheur
déjà aujourd'hui se cacher des choristes
huit millions et demi d'entrées
et ouais il s'est pris un poney en vo 81
tarn avait ignoré de vivre chaque fois
là je vais l'acheter mais pour l'instant
j'ai acheté en lego là pour l'instant
alors ma vie on est tendu n'êtes pas
autour du monde pour votre vin vous êtes
souvent à megève vous avez des
propriétés hôtelières et c'est à megève
que vous consacrez votre nouveau livre
qui s'appelle mesure en rebond d'amour
chez albin michel
oui alors c'est un petit village qui est
devenu un lieu de légende gerra incita
lieu de légende toutes les grandes stars
sont passés tous les hommes politiques
tous les hommes politiques ont eu des
romans d'amour là bas et ce qui serait
très amusant c'est de récupérer les
livres d'or du chalet du mont d'arbois
l'autre tête de mon arbre parce que tout
est noté vous le savez bien sûr et c'est
là on pioche avec est exactement vous
avez tout dit mais là j'aimerais qu'à
megève la neige et chauffer quand il
fait trop froid pour que les riches
s'enrhume pas non non quand on boit du
vin chaud à megève c'est du mouton
rothschild non c'est ma cousine ou temps
assez votre cousine moutons à dakar du
tuvalu me gêne ah ben moi j'aime bien
sur mes skis resto sympa pour 1000 euros
on peut déjeuner non un peu plus est une
ridicule avec son chapeau j'ai pas du
chapeau j'ai dit marc veyrat marc veyrat
son chapeau la majeure
alors ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
megève a été fondée par votre belle-mère
un an et demi de rothschild 1924 voilà
et pourquoi alors c'était une jeune
femme à cette époque et qui avec aimé le
ski et les mélos ce qui est elle allée
toujours à saint moritz la guerre arrive
et elle dit au directeur écouter ça me
gênerait beaucoup que je rencontre sans
arrêt des allemands dans vos couloir
alors si vous permettez je ne viendrai
plus je peux pas vous empêcher d'avoir
la clientèle que vous désirez mais je
vais partir et elle parle et elle va à
la recherche d'un endroit où elle
pourrait créer une station
elle envoie plusieurs val d'isère et
différentes stations et elle tombe sur
megève le mont d'arbois et là elle
découvre le bonheur un côté très féminin
dans les dans l'ambiance si vous voulez
de cette station qui n'était pas
difficile les femmes pouvaient faire du
ski à cette époque là ce qui n'était pas
évident et elle a acheté pratiquement
tous les terrains du mal à voir ce
qu'elle a fait c'est qu'elle a planté
des épicéas dépeint des mélèzes et
aujourd'hui ils ont 80 ans ces arbres
donc on a l'impression qu'ils ont
toujours été là en fait c'est votre
belle-mère qui les a plantés tout ça
parce qu'elle voulait pas voir le baron
croupe le roi de l'acier allemand dans
l'hôtel qu'elle fréquentait l'hiver donc
il a décidé de fonder une une citation
comme ça cela donnera cette histoire
voilà sa part non non je dis je ils
salissent et inquiète gta mais c'est bon
c'est bon tu as été à superdévoluy
j'étais partout moi j'ai fait le tour du
monde et passion c'est très joli en plus
c'est vraiment super dévoluy alors tout
de suite l'hôtel du mont d'arbois
devient le lieu de rendez-vous des têtes
couronnées tout le gotha et là faut dire
qu'il y avait 130 employés pour 130
clients
c'est pas comme chez hippopotamus a
alors non alors après le gotha et la
demande politique évidemment qui vient
le monde du spectacle et en 1963 il ya
eu cette grande fête interdite mandat
voilà pendant senteurs les gens ne se
sont pas couchées pratiquement c'est à
dire qu'ils ont vécu matin midi et soir
dans un bonheur total quatre jours ça a
failli dormez la nuit tombée le jour
juste parce qu'il faisait n'était pas la
dernière puisque j'attendais mon fils
vettier coucher et que je n'ai pas pu en
profiter alors c'est incroyable parce
que les rockefeller arrive il ya plus de
place pour eux et votre mari achète le
chalet des bourbon parme en raison comme
ça on saura où les mettre exactement
c'est aujourd'hui le chalet du mont
d'arbois
on a revendu dans totem c'est la dolce
vita finit bien c'est jusqu'à midi si
rien n'est touché à cinq heures du matin
venez manger des soupes à l'oignon aux
enfants terribles
non j'avais surtout un mari qui ne se
couchait pas secours alors ça c'était
c'était très difficile à vivre mais il
fallait l'accepter j'avais pris
j'accepte donc on se couchait à 5 heures
du matin à 9 heures on partait faire du
ski et on recommence et le lendemain
voilà
et ça a duré un certain nombre d'années
je crois que mes toiles en cuisine non
non ce qui vous attend ce qu'est
annoncée jamais franchi le pas en flèche
non non non
j'en ai cinq déjà au blason des
rothschild ça me suffit et alors tu
compris j'ai trois étoiles les jours du
mariage de votre mari est rentré à 4
heures du matin oui ouais donc tu savais
que j'allais l'épouser pas ce qu'on me
dit toujours mais est ce que tu crois
que ton mari et si on écoute il est
rentré à 4 heures du matin donc je
savais exactement ce qui m'a les matins
il a continué d'ailleurs après françoise
françoise 3h01 oui voilà vous battez et
on va faire une équipe là c'est en tout
cas c'est des mariages qui ont duré
regard des affaires en temps voilà et
toi ça fait combien à 30 ans 37
non je crois que pour qu'un mariage dure
il faut laisser une liberté totale on
n'a pas le droit d'enquêter dans la vie
des gens je crois vous fait dire cela
dressé à nos épouses
françoise david olivier s'il vous plaît
disques durs il faut vous êtes l'exemple
même en tous les cas de la cccoi mari
allait voir les call girls du tout ça
vous ne voulez pas une signature non
plus à porter sur cinq ans alors qu'en
faut pas aller à megève
c'est l'intersaison qui effectivement
est difficile et puis les gens sont en
vacances et les commerçants sont en
vacances il faut bien qu'ils se reposent
ma vie une caisse qui est trop chère à
megève
mais tout est trop cher en saison en
dehors de la saison c'est beaucoup moins
cher mais un forfait sait combien la
forfait mais c'est vrai c'est déjà très
cher est inclus dans le forfait
justement qu'est ce qui est inclus dans
le forfait cette question à nos
questions combien ça coûte
c'est tellement de prix un forfait des
enfants ce qui est des forfaits et
forfaits avec neige pour faits non vous
en trouverez toujours maintenant parce
qu'ils achètent des stations pauvre
d'accord sur la terre c'est bon de le
faire bien sûr puisque la neige la neige
a tendu la main aux jeunes familles à
verdon mais je sais pas où il est à
bientôt traduit la bonne c'est l'heure
qu'est ce qui vous énerve le plus à
megève année j'aime le fait que les
paysans ne met pas à cette fleur sur les
balcons les hôteliers haut ce qu'est ce
qu'ils foutent non et je suis vous et
des bananes et des cornichons
sans déconner et pourtant ces jolies une
station de ski avec des fleurs sur les
vans et bien sûr voilà alors je crois
qu'il faudrait faire un effort de ce
côté là est ce qu'on peut se faire
inviter une semaine tous frais payés à
megève sketches alors monsieur m'a dit
non mais si si non non c'est toi la
machine à musique
non
lège
en quoi la chanson dont les montants de
l'adamo cette chanson tu te souviens pas
et je mets des paroles ce qui est certes
et rooney
[Musique]
et
obernai
qui sait c'est à notre génération c'est
anne inédit de françoise hardy
[Musique]
et
s'en vante pas de celui-là je veux bien
mais aussi françois sont un des sketches
tous les merdes
bon alors nadine peut-être bientôt un
nouveau métier la télé vous avez
commenter le mariage de l'infant felipe
et de lætitia artistes pour la
télévision suisse romande et vous êtes
drôlement demandé par les chaînes
françaises souvent de vous demande de
faire une émission
et oui quand j'avais 18 ans personne ne
me demandait maintenant que jamais 72
sont nombreuses
alors je pense que c'est là que jean
claude narcy ou charles villeneuve toute
façon donc c'est très bien rêver oui je
pense franchement mais ça vous branche
tv sérieux n'ont pas dit non non vous
faire une télé réalité avec quinze mecs
qui voudra gaymard jeune mercy ferme
avec la terre ne m'a rien sur la somme
c'est un peu un mélange de vincent mc
doom est donnée de gilbert en fait
j'espère que ce soit pour se faire
gentiment 4 la semaine de vacances
allogènes ont alors en parle toujours
toujours toujours de vos bonnes manières
moi je suis sûr que vous aussi des
mauvaises manières non pas à ma
connaissance mais peut-être on va voir
you bad girl votre plus grosse gaffe au
cours d'un dîner
c'était en amérique et le kennedy était
mort et johnson était allait être élu
président et à ce moment là il y avait
effectivement comme dans tous les grands
dîners mondains et politique les gens
donné beaucoup d'argent et nous devions
attendre l'arrivée de johnson et à un
moment donné il était deux heures du
matin j'en ai eu absolument marre je
suis parti et en arrivant dans la
cuisine je suis tombé sur johnson &
johnson m'a dit mais où allez vous
madame
je lui ai dit écoute et j'attends le
futur président j'en ai marre inac
arriver à l'heure je m'en vais et je
suis parti il est rentré dans le salon
il a dit à mon mari du don ces petites
françaises elles sont pas faciles à
vivre
alors voilà c'était la seule gaffe de ma
vie je regarde votre gros mots préférés
nadine mais j'aime bien tout seul non
non je les aime bien tous j'en ai pas
être préféré honnêtement jute ou fluo
non à une grosse crotte crotone non une
chose que je n'aime pas c'est metz non
ce qu'on dise carrément merde oui pas
mal à votre pire faute de goût matière
faute de goût
c'est ce soir au
oui
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un
peu de bleu